um well how are you what can I help you
with man okay how often how often are
knows this happen it just means whenever
one man's point of view and this takes
away a lot of psychological things that
I could never ought it like real
depression things of that nature but
like from like just even vibe I don't
think that's what we're dealing with it
just means you're not doing the thing
you love the most I believe that to be
true I feel like I feel like that's a
classic example of somebody who's
motivated and it's like generally happy
and once to make stuff happens but it's
just not doing what they want to be
doing cool the only time I get into that
pattern is when I'm not doing what I
want to be doing that pattern hasn't
really existed since I got out of school
you know the worst I was a terrible
student I punted it I um I thought it
was not for me and not the disrespectful
what like you know it's great when I say
him now because people know I went on to
be successful and so I was being fair I
wasn't like a loser who's like ah school
and then I just want to do more loser
things I was like damn it this is not
built for me like I don't give a [ __ ]
about the Catcher in the Rye like these
symbols for [ __ ] salt are gonna do me
no good you know but like but if they
like god forbid you know it's funny
history I did well because I thought I
saw patterns it's how I do business
history tells you the future it's one
predicting stuff it's you know it's it's
pattern recognition that was cool
hey don't let these things happen
because that's how Wars start hey don't
let these things happen that's how like
you know suppression of information can
have like that was good but like other
things that I knew weren't gonna be me
so I struggled with it but I struggled
with it
in hindsight by being respectful to it
knowing it worked for others schools not
stupid for everybody school was stupid
for me so that's how I dealt with it I
knew that from a very early age I'm self
aware for the most part right and like
I've grown into it obviously but yeah I
knew it apparently a young age yes I
think yeah so I think I think the thing
that I'm trying to accomplish is I'm
trying to just make it a conversation I
don't think I'm gonna solve
self-awareness but I sure love to be a
little tiny sliver and all the people if
I can talk about it so much that it
becomes a cool thing to talk about is 25
year old business men and women and one
of them goes on to do that you know I'd
like to be part of it because boys at
the game what's it called
Russia and what it cut like how do you
translate yeah she's right you're lucky
if you're if you have one if you're
lucky enough to have a mom that believes
in that no wonder you got to this moment
myself to be not conventional
entrepreneur you are honestly money is
something that gives sure but I don't
seems like my goal and of course helping
people that you do is the way you get
there's so many ways to do the right
thing and the selfish thing and there's
a lot of different patterns some spend
fifty years of the life being
unbelievably selfish and then deploy
unbelievable generosity you know my big
thing is the content right like like I
have entrepreneur friends who like buy
an umbrella give an umbrella or 110
cents out of everything I'm like and I
debate with them social entrepreneurs to
my homie is first of all 80% of them are
using good as a disguise for their truth
let's call a spade a spade the 20% that
I'm able to sniff out that are legit we
have amazingly deep conversations cuz
I'm like look cool like you know my
autobiography is called the honey Empire
in my own head I think I'm gonna build
enormous success and I think I'm gonna
do it the best way possible I think I
think this thing that somebody just sent
me is very true to me which is I don't
care about how much money is in my bank
account I do care about how many why the
[ __ ] in my meeting with you
I need this five minutes my man like to
be very frank with you right
I need this five minutes I'm doing it
because intuitively it feels like it
felt like the right thing to do based on
the email I don't know it's very random
right and so I think there's a lot of
ways to do good there's a lot of ways to
do good and I think the thing you find
out is I think too many young
entrepreneurs who think they're doing
good don't realize the money's not the
part it's not the part do you know much
easier it is for me to sign a hundred
thousand dollar check to a charity now
than it is to be on the board of a
charity I need my time right so if all
these homies are like yes but I give a
percentage backlink I'm like I'm like
the money is the easy part
how about bringing value to the
ecosystem right how about putting in
work and so I I the most confusing thing
I do in public is I leave a lot of money
on the table by being garyvee most
people watching this right now think the
way I built my personal brand is why I
have this wealth because they don't
understand that I actually built a
business long before I was anybody and
if I spend every hour and every piece of
energy I'm actually just building
businesses like the one you're in right
now I'd have more money not less but
what I do with this is kids in Toronto
can watch it and use it to build their
future literally literally and honestly
that's why I apply listen a real
pleasure I'm sure we'll get to see each
other again
definitely yeah man good luck let's do
it no races that's new selfie selfie guy
yeah let's get some of the video I got
to start taking interview awesome I
forgot to yeah
love your vibe
you